but Sam Adams forced me to thank you
well then force me gave me a reason a
commercial happy but day that we're
gonna hear it now you want to hear it
chair now yeah hit it I'll tell you can
do it actual now we all right here dummy
second I remember that Brennan and I
were we were so let me yeah so they
asked I think so
they asked Whitney Cummings Tom Segura
jo koy Theo von in Ari Shaffir and
myself so it's six comics they're doing
this campaign of you know basically
saying thanks appreciates the people
that got you to where you at your career
and yeah I was lucky enough to be part
of this and it was funny as they you
know they get on a call for creative
there you go so here's my idea man we we
just you know we don't know who would be
in your career you know to to give
thanks to where you're at now you're
Albright County well you know most
people take three or days in three or
four days a thing baguette my Dhoni is
Bryan Callen he goes oh okay you sure
know yeah dude I don't need a creative
like it's Bryan counties it's for my
career
it's Brian Kelly's alright well that
makes it easier okay cool but I was
thinking when I got the phone I you know
I've been funny if I would toast Dana
White can we do another spoof and I
toasted Dana White he was you think he'd
be into it I oh I don't know I was gas
rolling like dude hit up dance if he's
dancing and doing this commercial with
me that'd be hilarious
let everybody know I want to toast you
for sign that Reebok dealin beam after
taking me Matt just being mean to me cuz
put the biggest chip on my shoulder
yeah and I'm that's where I'm at man yes
I have no animosity towards me at all
but now I would help the UFC however I
can you know yeah but it'd been funny
huh even if it is huge it would be gotta
be what day we're like we don't want any
sort of joke stuff like that but it's a
very good commercial all right hit it
being a comedian is the greatest my
basement on earth real basements
difficult job check out the locks like I
used to fight grown man in this steel
cage my underwear
this is a great commercial with Sam
Adams to think legacy the foundation of
what America is about
the idea that Oh someone is important
because with so much content these days
in social media there's so much
negativity it's very rare where you stop
and actually make knowledge showing that
who actually matters she's not through a
tweet I'll throw a picture on Instagram
it's important do something like this we
know how everybody's movie ends
especially when it comes to boxers or
fighters you stick around long enough
everybody ends up face down but up on
the canvas
there's no longevity in it I'm on this
rocky sea and it's foggy and I don't
know where I'm going I'm lost
and Brian Callens my lighthouse so you
would remind me that there's more to
life than fighting
and I was getting ready to spar this
giant guy they would give him $500 if he
knocked me out
and so he's this killer and he walks in
this gym and I start making fun of him
not mean but just kind of roasting what
he's wearing and how big he is and Brian
goes you know you're gonna stand up
right
I was like yeah you're crazy but Brian
just kept planting that seed that meant
the world to me the world well no one's
worse at smelling the roses and the two
of us stopping and smelling the roses
the worst yeah I never do but I wanted
to stop and take a moment man and cheers
you because you saw something me that I
even see in myself and since day one
you've pushed me to get better and
better as a stand-up comic and try not
to laugh but also look at a hundred ten
years old good like a fossil Oh like you
7,000 years oh sorry
is Britney toasting your mommy and that
extra zipper this well do you feel like
buttons are not enough or is this a
feature it's just kind of like oh it
just makes me angry when you're that
fashionable for some reason let's go
enjoy your beer Boston lager
that's a great camera great that's ape
and I love it I think they said they
said the owners of Sam Ann's this
campaign cried during two peoples
commercials Joe Khoisan this one yeah at
the fact that little [ __ ] mercy
lighting the lighting dude whoa go back
to that freeze-frame I feel I got a
crazy issue you don't look like that I
think it's just the light I guess that's
now my dad 79 I don't think I think he
looks better leave your jowls I mean
look at the [ __ ] cheeks in the eyes
that's a disaster
you don't really like no but I look
every bit of 65 65 yes look 77 years you
said I was gonna be 76 years old
tomorrow you I'd go he looks cool I
don't know you're right man but that can
mean something through some [ __ ] well I
mean talk about [ __ ] weathered that's
a beautiful commercial thank you yeah I
think that's a beautiful car
this is Wow all know it Oh Bryan Callen
God you look great on camera Jesus
Christ no man fell bro I couldn't be
happier with his hair like that it is
getting you look right without hair
thanks dude
I don't look good you look great he's
going out with us hey how often my face
looks like a barrel of snakes so
different face looks like a barrel of
snakes my Facebook's their own sponsored
bills Nate just a bunch of Harold baked
it so dirty I a bribe can we tie his
face back to school his face is falling
off his skull you know it was uh do I
have the worst that same thing oh man it
was awkward even we got our we have our
way to do it
and if you keep being us all right
fellas kind of tighten it up I was
[ __ ] around the old thing well I was
beautiful I was worried cuz uh Greg I
think I was i I don't know if like the
last one my chute or whatever but I was
like if everybody else is like funny cuz
this ain't funny man there's like the
question they're asking are like this
this ain't that funny if I'm across
cause if you're looking for funny man we
need to reshoot that's a beautiful no
it's not they want to go we don't want
funny funny very it's a you caught it
you come across that's a really good
commercial I love it I got a I'm gonna
send that to my parents the other thing
too because they'll love that
yeah they wanted to debut it on finding
the kid and then they're gonna post it
great at Sam Adams next week they aired
it during the Boston Bruins game is it
smart to buy oil of olay is it sponsored
by LaVon I
from my face for youth creep wow man
that's it that's beautiful you what
school it all not cool they're gonna
send me the footage but they had a bunch
of footage of tiger mean tiger run
around and wrestling let's meet him when
I get home and me it's on meaning my
wrestling say it all this footage and he
does man we if such a different
commercial with tiger as a fun
commercial but because it's alcohol they
we can't help a with it I was like Oh
put up core kind of a perfect camera I
loved it
now who else who did thank who else
thanked who Whitney thanked her
assistant slash like producer I think
for a podcast cool jo koy I think this
mom go to joy coach go to Sam Adams
comer it might be Sam Adams it's already
I thought you joke we posted it on his
page ready today but if you're Sam at
odhh he posts it today what is it
threaded I know I know I'm the last one
to pull her this first one I'm gonna
post time I know I haven't seen this but
I heard have you seen Jose I saw this is
it that's what they said they cried at
mine and others they cried out mine
because they're afraid you were going to
die any second I'm gonna post a [ __ ]
commercial on my Instagram that's
beautiful let's see this one else's I'm
Jo koy stand-up comedian and I'm here to
toast my mother and he's the nicest
Denver and none of this would have
happened since day one I wanted to make
sure that the world could laugh you're
doing great and then probably you wanted
me to be a lawyer
well we digress Sam Adams it's
grassroots it's family and that's why
Sam Adams is the best beer for this
toast
the reason why I brought you here today
is I wanted to toast you this is hard
harder than I thought thank you for
everything you sacrificed
[Music]
so this is for you damn Joe and I toast
you and I love you so much
thank you I love you love you too I got
bottoms up slow down ladies slow down
lady
I love you geez man you want some more
great yeah uh who else is there
I'm telling if you go to Sam Adams they
have all of them up except for maybe
mine and Tom's me and Tom are the last
ones to pose Samuel Adams there it is
are you over 21
yes but yeah toast someone it's really
good commercial man aren't they cool
jeez then there's wait there's re-read
ban I don't know him and Batman were so
close
there's Theo there's Jo koy and then Oh
mines up now but they want the
once-proud they want me to post it next
week this okay so so so they we can't
see the ones that are not yeah you can
see all those let's eat so Tom's is the
last one they go I think he posted it on
Todd yesterday though I saw it they just
want to spread it out but why won't you
do it for things who did who Tom thanked
his wife Kristina oh I want to see is it
fine oh it's funny
give me funny that's twittery Center man
Jesus Christ she's so much better than
ours
great oh dude have you seen Tom we'll go
to after this but Tom's dancing thank
you to me the idea of toasting someone
is exciting I love the idea of toasting
someone and saying that a lot of what I
get credit for is because of you Sam ed
was for me
reminds me of friends and family it's
the perfect beer of tow somebody would I
chosen to toast my wife I could think of
nobody more deserving to be toasted I
have nothing but amazing things in my
life - a beautiful boy they're [ __ ]
great these they're all of it is
directly tied to having you by my side I
know how hard you work so that we can
have my stuff I [ __ ] love those to
you oh thank you
I love you I love you I can't believe
we've been together for so long I know
it's time to move on but for the time
those are my neighbor 22-year old dummy
those are my neighbors that our kids are
similar age that's amazing uh go to let
me see you Ari's
[Music]
to being a comic is the best no no man
people talk about how hard it is right
now but it's not a lot of comics talking
about like leave us alone it's just
jokes like no they're not just jokes
they're important powerful words and we
get to hit people with him all the time
when you came to me and said hey Sam
Adams says is there anybody you want to
toast your life said goddamn right there
is what better way than a toast to share
beer and you say hey no more sips until
we all agree this next step is for this
thing and so I thought let's all have a
sip for Brian Redman so if I'm gonna
make a toast
absolutely Sam Adams was a great beer
for that when I was maybe five years in
I mean I was scraping by at the time the
only way comedians could like get any
press you have morning radio did sucked
we'd always dream about like we had a
radio show but there was no outlet for
them and then Brian's cousin gasps
starters he finds a smart buyer you got
it
yes nope I can't believe you can't get
one Brian Redman we call him the pod
father and he's the pod father because
he got all these podcasts started read
back him to me and he was like let's
start podcasts let's do want and I try
to fight him for a while because I was
always real addicted to my failures you
know yes
addicted to my failures in Sydney he got
me to do a podcast and it just sorta
taking off I got listeners I got
followers I've developed a fan base
because I've reached out on that podcast
and I couldn't have done it without this
dude Brian Redman that's amazing yes
that's a great one to [ __ ] where I
was nine years ago before you forced me
to brew a podcast I mean I was doing
nothing with my career yeah you were I
mean a little I was working hard on
stage but I was a loser like career was
I have a way to reach my fan base now I
can make a living as a comically a mark
morning radio no more morning radio you
make your own schedule and you help
yourself out you owe me a lot of money I
was starving I do owe you a lot of money
you owe me a lot of us one of the
cheapest comedians in the world I can
never repay you financially but what I
can do to give you a Sam Adams and I
want to toast you because honestly if
the toast I want is to recognize them
and if anybody needs recognition it's
you thank you for all the well I love
Ari - Ari such an honest man dude
brother it's such a phenomenal calming
man God they're both just greatness it's
great to see that [ __ ] I listen to see
this [ __ ] any cool man
yes
[Music]
music - whoever chose this music this is
me playing the it diovan kind of wild
right now life's gotten pretty crazy it
just kind of blows my mind sometimes I
have an opportunity to toast anyone that
I want I'm gonna toast the audience that
comes to my shows this next guy is one
of my favorite people in the whole world
to watch you're very very lucky to see
her I don't drink alcohol but I wanted
to be part of this campaign because
toasting is such a simple act of
kindness letting somebody know that you
recognize them letting somebody know
that they mean something to you thank
you dude a lot of recognition these days
is liking something or sharing something
it's just so fleeting the value of that
but on the breaks let somebody know they
mean something to you
I realized the other day I look like
somebody who knows where the rabies at
Sam Adams is the permit for a toast is a
traditional vibe to it turn about
reincarnation bro you know cuz I'm
planning on doing it again you know he's
fantastic Laughlin I feel like we get
advertising one thing but delivered
something else people deserve to get
something for their money when I see a
couple sitting there maybe they hired a
babysitter and this is their one night
of the month that they go out and do
something fun a mother and son that will
come out to the show or a pair of
brothers I want to make a toast actually
to you guys you guys always continue to
come back and allow me to really follow
my dream you know like this is my dream
for years I would get to the venue and
there wouldn't be anybody there
that's why it's important to me to put
on the best show you know I couldn't
live my dream if there weren't an
audience so I want to toast you guys the
audience for always being there for me
and meet me in every city that I go to
anybody can be toasted it's something we
[ __ ] telling each other
I see you and thank you if your next
beer is the same Adams tonight it's on
me everybody in the house and thank you
very much from the bottom of my it's
cool Matthews yeah what teachers can
write yeah isn't a great campaign yeah
he was uh he was worried about doing the
commercial because you know he's sober
so you know for a while now so he
associated with BAM like but do it as a
comic man you know I think it shows
strength about geometry but you can be
around it and still do your job and like
hang out with us when he because he was
in Pittsburgh same time I was in
Pittsburgh came the Late Show I get are
you pretty [ __ ] up not that [ __ ] up
but I'm pretty tips I've I've fun it's a
good environment or fun so he came back
he was like oh dude you smell like whisk
him like yeah dude that's what I do man
this what the [ __ ] I do like I go out to
have a great time he's like oh wow well
you're you're you're such a disciplined
control guy that you never will ever be
in danger on having alcohol get in the
way of any oh no it's just some people
can't turn it off yeah and so that's
where it becomes you're a little drunk
now but anyway the things I thought I do
have a little Bailey's you know and
that's okay but dude it's a but you know
what it's 11 we're fine I don't feel
that I think shows strengthen shows
people that do have like alcohol issues
I've been around it is it's like you can
still be in the environment be of the
discipline not to [ __ ] with it I think
that was watching I remember I've known
Thea I guess now god I'm going back to
the the west side brewing day people
forget how long he's been doing it man
I've known Thea of I've been watching
Theo to stand up he's been around for at
least 15 he's been touring for 14 okay
so the guy the guy who shot this convert
well to go created this so Sam Adams
right hired someone to do this the guys
the they hired a guy to do this guy
named Kevin hmm I didn't know this but
you know Kevin's a big comedy fan you
know his comedies a brilliant guy him
his brother the ones you met him mm-hm I
like him his brother down the production
company but we're talking about Theo and
he goes oh yeah I mean Theo's one my
close friends or what he was yeah I've
known Thiel for 15 you sleep on my couch
and why didn't deal know each other very
well and you know but why so I'm doing
stand-up I was thinking about how yeah
where he's come from and and he goes
it's so crazy because you
at this time but for the longest time
Theo out offstage is the funniest person
you've ever been it like he would at
dinners like the finest person ever but
he could never he's always trying to be
someone else on stage right so it never
really worked so then not that didn't
work he'd still but he wasn't selling
any take it chair for the I remember
that year at 14-14 years yeah and then
finally he's like his true self on stage
and podcasting it did it don't forget I
mean know that then I was so I was
thinking about Theo was on road rules or
something like that how long ago was
that
I mean nineties so I don't do I i I've
technically I might have known Theo
maybe twenty years now which is
mind-blowing because I've known him as a
guy who was on road rules and was doing
a little bit of stand-up and I never
paid attention right and then I saw him
five years ago
maybe six years ago maybe a five do
stand-up and I went hey dude you're
[ __ ] really good and he never thought
of himself that way right you know but
but it's just weird to see him now okay
so it took him 20 years to become
successful welcome to the world you know
so anybody out there who's young and
well no I was again it took do 20 years
to find who really sure whatever the
case yeah yeah 95 is right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]